starting off this hour is going to be
Fred and Fort Worth Texas hey Fred
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey how
you doing better than I deserve how can
I help
yes my question today is when do you
stop paying minimum payments on credit
cards
well I wouldn't I would pay more than
minimum payments because I want to get
rid of the debt okay right correct
but when you're trying to what we're
trying to sell our home would shut down
our business we're trying to sell our
home to take care of a big hunk of that
but at this point without the business
income payment in amongst our next
impossible and so you're going to talk
about you so you sold your business I
didn't sell it I liquidated it okay so
you don't have an income when I have an
income but not from the business okay
what is your income sixty okay
and does your wife work outside the home
now okay how many children do you have
three and how many hours a week are you
working about 40 okay what did you used
to make with your old business oh
nothing you brought you closed it
because it wasn't going well correct
okay try catching up all right and all
right and how much is your house payment
it's actually with everything it's about
with taxes and insurance it's around a
thousand okay and how much credit card
debt do you have about 95 okay and
you're going to get that much out of the
equipment things you're selling from the
business no that's that's what's left
over and we hope to get about half of
that from our the sale of our house Oh
from the sell your house that's what you
said correct honey all right so the
house is up for sale and where are you
moving um about an hour away to where my
job is okay good
okay all right well that makes sense
although that's logical good and how
much other debt other than 90-thousand
on credit cards do you have
we've got a car payment and a how how
much do you have a different house well
just how okay we have about 95 much how
much do you own a car 95 how much do in
your car 15 okay all right good okay
well here let's walk you through this
what we teach people when they're in a
financial crisis which is what you're
hopefully temporarily are facing because
hopefully when you get this house sold
and you knock off forty five thousand of
your hundred and five thousand one
hundred and ten thousand dollars worth
of debt which includes your car being
paid off okay we're going to pay off the
car and then we're going to work our way
through the credit cards with the money
from the house sale when that happens I
think your budgets going to balance and
you do too right I hope so yeah yeah
well I think it's going to the math math
is there now of course that depends on
what you pay in rent when you move to
the other area but so we teach folks
when they're in a financial crisis is we
do what we call the four walls meaning
protect your home the four walls of your
home must be protected before you do
anything else and the four walls of your
home are if you're in seventh grade they
used to teach a thing called civics
class and a civics class talks about the
difference in needs and once and the
four walls are your needs okay in
necessities so to start with we buy food
and I want you to do a written budget
with your wife because she's scared and
and you're scared and worried too so the
written budget you have enough coming in
if you don't do anything else you can
buy food right right okay and then the
second thing I want you do is I want you
keep the lights and water on and if you
have food and lights and water we're in
good shape right and you can you can do
those two I know you can with the money
you're talking about easy and then I
want you pay the house payment until it
sells because you got to live there
so you got food shelter clothing even
you don't probably don't need much
clothing you probably have enough
that'll last for a little while we're
not talking about doing this for two
year
we're talking about doing this for two
months while this house sells right
right okay so we're probably going to
have a very limited clothing budget used
what's there we don't need to be going
clothes shopping but if we got a kid
that's you know outgrown everything in
sight you may have to move up a little
bit but we're going to be very very
conservative on clothing so food shelter
clothing transportation let's go ahead
and pay the car payment okay now if you
don't do anything but pay those things
you're going to be alright and I'm
positive with the numbers you gave me
you can do all of those things you keep
the house current the lights and water
on food basic clothing and car payment
and car and gas in the car to go to work
you can do those the credit cards then
don't get paid anything possibly but if
you can find some more money in a
written budget we're going to pay some
of those okay and here's the ones I
would pay I would pay the ones that you
are not going to pay off when your house
sells which is the largest ones balance
wise okay okay so you're going to list
your debts smallest to largest when the
house sells I'm going to pay your car
off and then I'm going to pay down those
credit cards write down the list
smallest to largest and that means the
first $30,000 of small credit card bills
are going to be the ones that are paid
when the house sells if anything is
going to get behind I'm gonna let those
get behind okay but my question on
paying the credit cards is the you know
I've communicated with a few of the
credit card companies and they're like
well we can't negotiate anything because
they don't care you're up today yeah
they don't care my question was should I
go ahead and not pay them no the only
way you're going to get them to
negotiate deeply is you're going to
destroy your credit and you know you're
going to not pay for six months or a
year and that's not what we're talking
about here okay the house is up for sale
right correct how long has it been on
the market it's been on for about three
months okay you probably need to look at
that Fort Worth markets not that slow
yeah it just myself
we're trying to be a top dollar
this speak because you know to help us
out but yeah but let they have been
reduce in it yeah but you're you know
you're you're you're in the middle of a
stressful situation and you got this
long commute so you want you want to get
closure on this chapter that's a bad
chapter we want to get it behind us and
move on so if they cost you five grand
so what get it behind you close it up
move on and I don't want you to give it
away but top dollar sounds like it's
overpriced because they'll Fort Worth
mark gets hot enough it should have sold
within three months all right and I bet
your Realtors telling you that I'm
alright well see things we can get the
price we're asking for it so I think
she's blowing I think she's blowing in
your ear hey have you been through
Financial Peace University we are not
okay I want you and your wife to go
through that is my guest I'm going to
pay for it okay thank you I've been
right where you are I remember being
scared and beat up you're going to be
better off than you think you are you've
learned some lessons through this
they're tough lessons but they're
thorough lessons you take care of your
family first brother then you worry
about the stupid credit cards and you'll
get to them you'll get it all worked
through a year from now it's going to be
a bad memory hold on hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show